So I know I don't have
a lot of time to talk.
So let me just sort of get right
smack into the middle of this,
I was asked to talk about urban
and transportation related
things, but I will sort of talk
a little bit more broadly.
We are a think tank based
in Sri Lanka history of,
we're about 12 years old,
but very much in the sort of ICT
policy and regulation space.
But then we started looking at
how can ICTs be used in other
sectors so
agriculture was one of those.
And since 2012 we've
been working on big data,
trying to use that for specific
developmental policy domains.
But the work is only
in Sri Lanka and
a little bit in Bangladesh.
So these are some problems
of interest to us.
Cities very much, we understand
that given the region that we
are located in, large amounts of
the population is in the cities.
And they're growing at a
tremendous rate which is not in
the most planned fashion.
So what can we do in that
scenario when there's limited
planning and limited sense of
data that we can bring to bear.
So primarily what we're
thinking of is using
data from mobile operators
as a proxy files,
as human sensors for
a lot of different things.
These are the four areas of the
research practice that I lead,
that it looks at.
One is conducting
the analytics for answering
specific problems in different
domains or to develop insights
that are fed in the specialists
working in these domains.
Deeply engaging with
the policy makers.
We actually, in a way,
come from the other side, not so
much from the analysis side but
given our historical
linkages with policy makers.
And working in that space,
trying to work with them and
the symbolic environment so
not just a policy maker but
in that specialist the domain
of transportation which can be
broadly defined.
Also studying the impacts
of it on society
privacy marginalization
competition issues.
So we do have sort of our
founder is a lawyer as well so
you know that's the area that we
sort of look at quite a bit just
because it's also an area that
sort of can counter some of
the work that we are doing
in terms of trying to limit
the impact.
And we want to sort of
bring evidence grounded in
reality into that discourse
on a regional level.
So that, for
example, we convened with sort
of regulators in the region.
We sort of talk to them on a
regular basis, also with ITU and
the related bodies in
the regional, APT, for example,
in trying to make access to
telecom data more easier for
others in the region and
developing guidelines.
So I'll just give you some
examples of what we are doing
with CDR data everyone knows
what CDR data is, so this is
essentially your metadata
every time you use your phone.
So when you make a call,
receive a call, send an SMS,
receive an SMS,
initiate an Internet session,
do a reload,
these get automatically created
in the network that
the operators have this data.
And this is metadata, so there's
no actual content and we've
got basically for about half
the population of Sri Lanka,
10 million plus people through
multiple years records,
pseudonymized so
we don't know who they are.
We don't know demographics,
we don't know economics, it's
just a mass of people's data.
So using that for a variety of
how things are trying to get
more granular and high frequency
estimates of population density.
Understanding changes in
population density, the dyno
cycle, circadian rhythms of
people moving into an out of
cities in terms of these
places that they leave behind.
And these do have implications,
for
example, this in
terms of transport.
What you see here is this is
Colombo City and the picture
shows the relative density of
a place relative to midnight.
So what it is like at 6:30,
12:30, 6:30 in the evening.
And so this is a weekend,
weekday so
during the weekday noon,
that's when you have sort of
Colombo City's population
densities highly saturated.
And the people are generally
coming from the regions outside
the city.
So you sort of have a sense of
where people are coming from,
what the population sort of
hotspots are and you can start
the thing, use this also as
a way to understand cities.
There's this thing about
whether cities are monocentric,
polycentric, what does that
mean for urban planning?
This is some of that insights
that inform that debate.
Also when you think about what
should the administrative
boundary, what should
the limits of the city be?
So Colombo is actually a very
small city compared to India,
Indian cities.
Since we are technically
the population is 550,000 but
daytime population is
excess of 1.5 million.
So you can start to think
the all imposing costs on
the city that aren't recovered,
from transportation to
garbage collection, etc.
So what should be the optimal
makeup of cities?
What should the boundaries be?
And you can start to play
around with interesting sort of
possibilities that you can do
with policymakers about what
should be the makeup
of the city.
Where you can start to increase
the boundaries to a certain
manageable population that is
still manageable in terms of
services that can be
delivered to them.
So we sort of engage with policy
makers on issues like this.
On transportation, for example,
we are sort of trying to think
this is essentially what we
do is because of all traces
that people leave behind.
We can construct the network
of mobility and we are doing
modularity optimization to set
of do some partitioning of this.
And so what essentially this
means is that each colored
region is a region where
the density of travel within it
is a greater than across.
And you can think of this
being plugged into last-mile
solutions, right?
If you have the bus that's
coming from point a to point b,
this would be where the three
wheel associations you might
want to have.
You can think more broadly and
think about sort of
localized transport schemes for
park and ride options
based on where people start and
where people end up.
We are also, for example,
starting to impacts of
new infrastructure,
this is work that I do with
Joshua Blumenstock from
University of California,
UC Berkeley.
Where we are looking at
developing new measures of
trying to understand the impact
of new infrastructure
on mobility and by extension
understanding the welfare
impacts on
the population over time.
Because if you can have this
data, you can understand its
short term, medium term,
long term impacts.
This is something that
we're doing right now,
the field work just
got completed.
We don't have a lot
of intelligence about
this 10 million plus people,
we don't know gender,
we don't know economics,
we don't know demographics.
So what we are trying to do is
an ideal scenario we would work
with operators to do phone
service through which we can
build a good training dataset.
But that's a little
difficult to accomplish so
we're doing a slightly next
best solution is sort of
a parallel activity when we've
used a purposive sample and
installed farm people
with mobile phones.
Make sure they are given enough
coverage of gender, age, and
economics, socioeconomics
level that they are in.
And have an app that captures
the cell phone behavior as
well as we do a survey on top,
a sort of the recapturing
GPS logs as well from
the smartphones.
But in order to build
understanding for
transportation policy, we are
asking questions every so often.
So between the time of 6 AM
to 9 PM, we are asking every
hour on the hour questions
like where are you,
what are you doing, if you are
going where are you going to,
and what form of
transport you're using.
Through which we can sort of,
we'll basically leverage this as
a training data to understand
the most of data that we have
on the other side with
the cell phone records.
But again, this data is sparse,
is not great for
understanding traffic
conditions.
There's VR data which is
good but doesn't kept for
very long in the networks.
It doesn't give you very fine
temporal resolution and so
we are trying to develop
algorithms to do CCTV
footage working with
the police department there.
Also trying to understand,
for example, based on
the circadian rhythms of people
connected to base station,
can we again identify regions
of high economic activity and
sort of understand whether
on the highly residential
to highly commercial
spectrum of areas.
But that is not good enough, so
we are also looking at satellite
imagery to understand urban
space a lot more that small.
The idea being that you can
make all these grand plans and
visions of what ICT should
be in 20, 30 years but when
you don't know what's actually
happening on the ground,
it's kind of pointless.
But we can also
leverage mobility,
this is basically using origin
constrained gravity model
to develop new and proxy
indicators of economic activity.
These track very well with night
time lights, but they have
the added advantage that this
is a finer temporal resolution,
you can think about
doing this weekly.
I mean, this is a great measure
of understanding on a very
localized basis so like
yesterday we were talking about
regions at a district level but
here you can potentially
go down, even further down.
So this is work in progress
that we're doing, and
we're feeding into the sort
of a visual statistics.
These are sort of broad
implications of this work
that we're working
with different domains.
So open and transportation
policy, epidemiology unit on
understanding disease
propagation.
Yeah.
So that's in a brief, the kind
of work that we're doing,
thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> A quick question
how closely are you working with
the government, does it matter,
these things in the sense
of policy recommendations?
>> So when we started this there
was absolutely no demand, we
sort of were under the radar by
purpose because we didn't know,
we needed to be said we had to
figure out all the implications.
So we didn't talk about it for
a good year and
a half and it took about
a year to negotiate the data.
So initially I would advise as I
said to some of you I was like
a Jehovah's Witness
going door to door,
have you heard
the word of big data?
But now it's more like
they will give us calls,
we are doing x, y and z.
So there was a huge amount of
policy enlightenment work in
the beginning doing workshops,
doing meetings
to tell them the different ways
that you can use this for.
So now it's at different
levels so it's not always that
the senior person knows,
a policy maker knows all of
the interactions that their
department is having with us.
So large amount but the help,
for example, is more tricky.
We are still working with them,
we are working with
the police department.
But that's a long
engagement of having for
long periods of time, yeah.
>> Great, thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]